[Music]
dr. strange
so dr. strange is the newest movie in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe designer
phase 3 now shit's crazy it stars
Benedict Cumberbatch's dr. Stephen
strange had a point the internet was
like hey you know who should play Doctor
Strange the batch of gum Burkle we got
our wish dr. strange is a neurosurgeon
he's super talented he's arrogant he's
cocky because we love our arrogant cocky
doctors I can't stress that enough this
movie is pretty much Greg House learns
magic he even sounds like him I don't
believe in chakras or energy or the
power of belief I believe in that
patient because one rainy night dr.
strange wrecks his car his hands are
crushed he's a neurosurgeon he needs his
hands now his hands kind of shake so in
a quest to find a way to stop the
shaking of the hands he comes across
these monks who were pretty much like
hey we teach magic if you want to learn
they stop the shaking of the hands happy
half dr. strange this doesn't really
enjoy the movie because dr. strange
really is an origin story and I love
that I love seeing the origin of this is
a pretty crazy character it's a
neurosurgeon who busts up his hands and
hey guess what he becomes a sorcerer
what I love is that he didn't want to be
a sorcerer the shitstorm that's coming
after him he didn't ask for it he didn't
go looking for he's not like okay yeah
let's protect the universe Tom Mads
Mikkelsen is evil sorcerers starting to
do some bad stuff that's going to damage
existence as we know it or at least our
realm of existence as we know it so now
he's just reaction is what he does but
it really is a great path seeing him
grow and learn and seeing him shed away
the layers of his arrogance is when this
movie starts acting like there's no way
this guy is going to be humble enough to
learn magic and if he does learn magic I
don't want him learning magic he's
probably gonna do some dick stuff but I
should go along the path it's great to
see him humble himself and ultimately
pretty much play out Tony Stark's origin
story just with magic and monks arrogant
guy learns the error of his ways and
becomes a hero I mean come on thankfully
it's pretty much Thor also it's pretty
much anyone but Captain America because
he was always awesome and always had
heart and kind of moved Thor's hammer
slightly and Benedict Cumberbatch was
great as Stephen strange he really was
there was a lot more humor in this movie
than I thought there would be I'm not
used to Benedict Cumberbatch being that
funny
I was actually
mostly pleasantly surprised by the humor
it's always good when a moment of humor
comes in a way that you're like Oh
didn't expect that work for the moment
an arrogant guy with no humor is just a
dick but there were moments in this
movie where something good happens
something cool happens you're like ooh
let it resonate let it sizzle let a
humor happen you're like I humor kind of
compromises that moment most of the time
the humor hits a couple of times the
humor does compromise I just would have
rather had an epic moment than a
humorous moment and there was one scene
of time - I was like one moment he is
having trouble making a portal and then
the next moment he is just the master of
portal you're like I die imagine you've
been at this for a while now have you
been doing this for years I mean in
Batman Begins I had no problem buying
the fact that he was training for a few
years I do not actually know how long
Doctor Strange was actually training in
magic after assume it was years I don't
think he'd be this good after a matter
of months Mads Mikkelsen was good in the
role that he was in I wish we had seen
him more man I saw more of the villain
there coffin out baddies and our good
guys have to stop the baddies that's
pretty much what it is he's not the most
useless villain you've ever seen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe not at all
he's not like Zemo and Civil War where
you're like I don't think you had to be
there at all really for civil war to
happen like clearly needs to be in this
movie to push the plot forward to make
it happen there's actually more about
that I'll talk in my spoiler video but
can't talk about it here no spoiler she
would tell Ejiofor I hope I say his name
right I feel like I've been
mispronouncing it all these years but I
should learn to pronounce it correctly
because the dudes a great actor and he
does add to this movie even Rachel
McAdams was good as a love interest
generally love interests or in movies
like this because like well you need to
humanize them so they need to have a
relationship the audience can connect to
it this one really does they do it right
because it's not really a romance it's
not a love interest because Stephen
strange clearly dude probably do closes
I'm saying the user sparingly and they
use her right to the point where she
actually does add in this seems that
she's in but visually man let's talk
about the visuals in this movie they
said there are so many moments of its
imagine a Throwdown like this imagine
looking through a kaleidoscope at a
cityscape and then you turn the thing
and the city starts folding in on itself
now imagine that but in that city this
folding in on itself there are people
fighting with magic in there seriously
fractals
and Tesser axis movie yeah are you
intrigued you're at least intrigued guys
in the end dr. strange doesn't break new
ground other than the fact that it's
magic in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the closest we had to that until this
time was Thor I know dr. nazi monocle
was talking about we're in the age of
magic but we really hadn't seen that
because it was still based on loki staff
which is essentially technology that we
see as magic which is what thor kind of
illustrate is a hybrid of both it's a
straight-up magic there's no way around
there's no tech running this the way
they use magic for fights is where the
unique nature of this film lives it was
a fun movie it was a visual spectacle i
had a great time with it I will say
Doctor Strange is certainly worth
watching you're gonna watch the movie
anyway it doesn't matter what I say but
I entered the movie enjoying this movie
enough to buy it on blu-ray for sure
alright guys so Doctor Strange have you
seen it what did you think about it yes
I do read the comments although it don't
respond to all the comments I read them
whatever you thought about Doctor
Strange comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]